AI Johnny Cash singing a Taylor Swift
song for example hello I'm not Johnny
Cash so it's going to be
forever or it's going to go down in
flames you can tell me when it's
over if the high was worth the pain got
a long list of EX lovers they'll tell
you I'm insane cuz you know I love the
players and you love the game and that
got rave reviews for the most part
people didn't care that they were
hearing the voice of a dead country
music legend singing some of the most
vapid lyrics imaginable they embraced it
in fact there were people who even said
that they preferred that to Johnny
Cash's original songs and that's why we
could be certain that eventually nearly
all of the content we consume on the
internet and nearly every movie and show
we watch and song we listen to will all
be generated by AI